بالضبط مساحه كانت في حدود ثلث صفحه مقال
كان بيكتبوا اسبوعيا ولسنوات مصطفى مشهور
وقت ان كان نائبا للمرشد الاخوان ثم وهو
مرشد الاخوان وكان اذا تغيب يكتب مكانه
احمد المالط المرشد الاخوان او الكاتب
الاخوان المعروف عبد المنعم سليم جباره
بمعنى ان هذه المساحه مخصصه للاخوان حين
توقفت الشعب استاجر الاخوان جرائد من اكثر
من مره من حزب الاحرار استاجروا الجريده
يعني كامله وليس مجرد مساحه حدث هذا مع
الجرنان اسمه الاسره العربيه ثم مع القران
اشهر اسمه افاق عربيه وكان طريقه الاخوان
في التعامل مع هذه الجريده ان هم يعني في
اماكن التوزيع يشترون الكميه كامله من عند
موزع او بائع الجرائد فكان بانطباع الذي
يذهب الى يعني همم شركات التوزيع ان هذه
ج- الجريده ليس لها مرتجع لا يعود منها
عدد واحد